.
>> I STAND SQUARELY BEHIND MY
DECISION.
AFTER 20 YEARS I HAVE LEARNED
THE HARD WAY THAT THERE WAS
NEVER A GOOD TIME TO WITHDRAW
U.S. FORCES.
HERE'S WHAT I BELIEVE TO MY CORE
IT IS WRONG TO ORDER AMERICAN
TROOPS TO STEP UP UP WHEN
AFGHANISTAN'S OWN ARMED FORCES
WOULD NOT.
>> THE INCOMPETENCE OF THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION ON THIS IS REALLY
OVERWHELMING.
THERE NEEDS TO BE RESIGNATIONS.
THERE NEEDS TO BE FIRINGS.
>> THIS MAKES ALL OF US ANGRY
BECAUSE IT WAS COMPLETELY
AVOIDABLE.
>> WHAT HAPPENS IN AFGHANISTAN
DOESN'T JUST STAY IN
AFGHANISTAN.
IT SPREADS LIKE A CANCER.
>> Bret: PRESIDENT BIDEN'S
SPEAKING TODAY AND CAN YOU SEE
THE FEAR, OBVIOUSLY, IN THE
PEOPLE RUNNING AWAY FROM THOSE
PLANES AT THE KABUL AIRPORT.
YOU CAN ALSO SEE IT ON THE FACE
AND IN THE VOICE OF ONE OF THE
REPORTERS IN THE PENTAGON
BRIEFING TODAY, A REPORTER, AN
AFGHAN WOMAN WHO HAS BEEN
COVERING THE PENTAGON BUT GO
BACK TO AFGHANISTAN.
TAKE A LISTEN.
>> EXPECT OVERNIGHT ALL THE
TALIBAN' [INAUDIBLE] THIS IS MY
FLAG.
THEY PUT THEIR FLAG.
WHERE IS MY PRESIDENT FORMER
PRESIDENT BEGANY.
HE HAS TO FIGHT FOR HIS PEOPLE.
I HAVE LOTS OF ACHIEVEMENT.
I LEFT FROM THE TALIBAN LIKE 20
YEARS AGO.
NOW WE GO BACK TO THE FIRST --
>> Bret: AFGHANISTAN'S PRESIDENT
ASHRAF GHANI LEFT THE COUNTRY
JUST TO PUT A COST ON WHAT THE
U.S. HAS SPENT IN THE TOTAL COST
OF THE WAR, $978 BILLION FROM
2001 TO 2020.
NOT INCLUDING, OBVIOUSLY, THE
BLOOD AND TREASURE LEFT THERE.
LET'S BRING IN OUR PANEL SENIOR
POLITICAL ANALYST BRIT HUME, BEN
DOMENECH, PUBLISHER OF THE
FEDERALIST.
HAROLD FORD JR. FORMER TENNESSEE
CONGRESSMAN AND COE OF
EMPOWERMENT AND ENCOLLUSION
CAPITAL AND TREY GOWDY FORMER
CONGRESSMAN FROM SOUTH CAROLINA.
THE PRESIDENT'S SPEECH ON THIS
DAY?
>> WELL, THE PRESIDENT'S SPEECH
WAS ABOUT THE ONE THING THAT HE
KNOWS IS STILL POPULAR AND THAT
IS THE IDEA OF GETTING OUT OF
AFGHANISTAN.
BUT, FOR MUCH OF THE SPEECH I
DIDN'T FIGURE OUT WHAT WAR --
WHAT SO-CALLED WAR HE WAS
TALKING ABOUT.
WE HAVE BEEN GETTING OUT OF
AFGHANISTAN GRADUALLY SLOWLY FOR
YEARS AND YEARS.
WE WERE DOWN NOW IN THAT COUNTRY
TO ABOUT 2500 AMERICAN SOLDIERS
ON THE GROUND.
NO AMERICAN SOLDIER HAD BEEN
KILLED THERE IN A YEAR AND A
HALF.
BUT THAT LITTLE MODEST FORCE
WITH THE AIR POWER, THE
INTELLIGENCE AND LOGISTICAL
SUPPORT AND ADVICE THAT CAME
WITH IT, WAS ENOUGH TO MAINTAIN
KIND OF AN UNEASY STALEMATE IN
THAT COUNTRY.
THE PRESIDENT COMES ALONG AND
BLOWS THE WHOLE THING UP BECAUSE
HE WANTS TO GET OUT.
WE WERE GETTING OUT.
AND IT MATTERED HOW WE GOT OUT.
IT ALWAYS MATTERS HOW YOU GET
OUT IN A SITUATION LIKE THIS
WITH DRAWLS AND EVACUATIONS ARE
VERY MILITARILY TRICKY AND
DANGEROUS.
AND THIS ONE HAS BEEN UTTERLY
AND COMPLETELY BOTCHED.
APART FROM SAYING THEY DIDN'T
EXPECT IT TO GO DOWN HERE THIS
FAST, THE PRESIDENT DID NOTHING
TO EXPLAIN HOW THAT HAPPENED OR
WHY IT HAS GONE SO BADLY.
>> Bret: TREY GOWDY?
I KEEP THINKING OF THE WORD OF
ROBERT GATES NOT THE REPUBLICAN
CONGRESSMAN WE JUST PLAYED BUT
OBAMA'S FORMER SECRETARY OF
DEFENSE WHO SAID JOE BIDEN FOR
FOUR DECADES WAS WRONG ON NEARLY
EVERY MAJOR FOREIGN POLICY AND
NATIONAL SECURITY DECISION
THAT'S ROBERT GATES SAYING THAT
FOUR DECADES WORTH.
I'M HAPPY HE KEPT A CAMPAIGN
PROMISE BECAUSE HE SEEMS REALLY
REALLY INTERESTED IN DOING THAT
I'M JUST SORRY FOR Y'ALL THE
CARNAGE LEFT BEHIND BECAUSE HE
DID.
>> Bret: IT HAS BEEN INTERESTING
TO WATCH THE EVOLUTION OF THE
WEEK AND HOW THIS TRANSPIRED
VERY QUICKLY.
TAKE A LISTEN.
>> THIS IS NOT JUST ABOUT THE
OVERALL IDEA OF LEAVING
AFGHANISTAN.
THIS IS ABOUT LEAVING HASTILY
AND INEPTLY.
SECRETARY BLINKEN, HOW DID
PRESIDENT BIDEN GET THIS SO
WRONG?
>> SO, WAS HE MISLEAD BY HIS OWN
INTELLIGENCE AGENCIES?
DID HE NOT LISTEN TO THEM?
WHY WAS HE SO WRONG ABOUT THAT?
>> MR. BIDEN, WHO HASN'T BEEN
SHY ABOUT CHANGING ALL SORTS OF
OTHER POLICIES HE INHERITED FROM
IRAN TO CLIMATE CHANGE, WHY WAS
HE UNWILLING TO CHANGE THIS
POLICY?
>> THERE HAS BEEN AN IMPLOSION
OF U.S. POLICY, AND I THINK
SOMEONE GETS FIRED FOR THIS.
IN MY OPINION IT WOULD BE
SECRETARY BLINKEN.
THIS IS NOT THE MILITARY'S
FAULT.
THIS IS AN INTELLIGENCE FAILURE
HERE IN WASHINGTON.
>> Bret: HAROLD, REACTION TO ALL
OF THAT?
>> WELL, FIRST OFF, THANKS FOR
HAVING ME.
LOOK, I THINK, BRIT AND TREY ARE
ABOUT RIGHT IN THIS SENSE.
PRESIDENT BIDEN DECLARED TO THE
COUNTRY THREE OUT OF FOUR
AMERICANS AGREE WITH HIM THAT
AMERICA SHOULD NOT BE IN
AFGHANISTAN ANY LONGER.
THERE IS NO DOUBT.
WE ACCOMPLISHED A LOT OF WHAT WE
INTENDED TO ACCOMPLISH.
I WAS IN CONGRESS 9/11.
WE BELIEVED THAT JIHADISTS AND
AL-QAEDA WERE OPERATING FROM
AFGHANISTAN.
WE SENT FORCES THERE TO KILL BIN
LADEN AND WE DID.
ANY TIME YOU PROJECT MILITARY --
AMERICAN MILITARY INTO
ENGAGEMENT WITH A CLEAR
OBJECTIVE OR A DESIRED OUTCOME,
THEY GENERALLY DO VERY, VERY
WELL.
BUT, YOU INVITE TROUBLE AND YOU
INVITE DISAPPOINTMENT, YOU
INVITE UNDESIRED OUTCOMES WHEN
THE DEFINED PURPOSE IS NOT SO
DEFINED.
OVER THE LAST SEVERAL YEARS, IT
WAS NOT.
HE HAD THAT RIGHT.
BUT, WITHOUT QUESTION, HE, BEING
PRESIDENT BIDEN.
BUT, WITHOUT QUESTION, THEY HAVE
BOTCHED THIS EXIT.
THIS NATIONAL SECURITY TEAM OF
HIS, THE PRESSURE IS MOUNTING IN
MANY, MANY WAYS FOR THEM TO FIX
THIS EXIT PLAN FOR ALL OF OUR
AFGHAN ALLIES.
I WOULD HOPE THOSE OF US WHO
WISH TO BE CRITICAL OF THE
PRESIDENT.
I DON'T WISH TO BE CRITICAL OF
HIM.
BUT WISH TO BE CRITICAL OF HIM
PLEASE DO NOT CONFLATE THE TWO.
THE EXIT FROM AFGHANISTAN IS THE
RIGHT THING TO DO.
WE HAVE OTHER PRIORITIES WE NEED
TO FOCUS ON.
AND IF BY SOME CHANCE
AFGHANISTAN BECOMES A WOODSTOCK
FOR JIHADISTS WE WILL BE ABLE TO
COALITION WILLING MORE RESOLUTE
ONE UNDER PRESIDENT BUSH IF THAT
IS INDEED THE CASE.
BUT THEY HAVE TO FIX THIS EXIT
PLAN.  THIS WILL BE PRESIDENT
BIDEN'S ACHILLES HEEL IF HE DOES
NOT.
>> Bret: YOU KNOW, WE DIDN'T
HEAR ABOUT THE RULES OF
ENGAGEMENT FOR THOSE TROOPS
TRYING TO GET ALL THOSE PEOPLE
OUT.
WE DIDN'T HEAR HOW LONG THE AIR
BRIDGE REALLY IS GOING TO RUN IN
THE PRESIDENT'S SPEECH.
AND JUST IN THE PAST FEW
MINUTES, BEN, ASSOCIATED PRESS,
U.S. DEFENSE OFFICIAL CONFIRMS
TALIBAN'S SUDDEN ACCUMULATION OF
U.S. SUPPLIED AFGHAN EQUIPMENT
IS, QUOTE:  ENORMOUS.
>> YOU KNOW, THIS IS A TRAVESTY
IN SO MANY WAYS.
AND I DO THINK THAT WE HAVE TO
SEPARATE THE POLICY HERE FROM
THE EXECUTION.
THE POLICY IS BROADLY POPULAR.
AND I HEARD THE PRESIDENT COME
OUT AND DEFEND THE POLICY OF
LEAVING AFGHANISTAN.
BUT IT'S A SPEECH THAT HE COULD
HAVE GIVEN SIX MONTHS AGO.
AND IT REALLY DIDN'T WRESTLE
WITH ANY OF THE ACTUAL QUESTIONS
THAT PEOPLE HAVE OVER WHAT THEY
HAVE SEEN OVER THE PAST SEVERAL
DAYS.
PARTICULARLY AS IT RELATES TO
ANY KIND OF CONFIDENCE THAT WE
CAN HAVE IN OUR MILITARY
LEADERSHIP AND OUR INTELLIGENCE
COMMUNITY THAT PROMISED THAT
SOMETHING LIKE THIS WAS GOING TO
TAKE MONTHS IF IT HAPPENED AND,
FRANKLY, WE LOOK BACK AT THAT
PRESS CONFERENCE, THAT THE
PRESIDENT HAD, WHERE HE WAS
DOING ALL THIS HAPPY TALK ABOUT
THE IDEA THAT THE AFGHAN
MILITARY WAS PREPARED, THAT
TALIBAN LEADERSHIP WAS NOT A
FORGONE CONCLUSION.
THAT HE EXPECTED THEM TO FIGHT,
ET CETERA.
AND THE QUESTION REALLY BECOMES
IS THAT WHAT HE REALLY BELIEVED?
IS THAT WHAT HE WAS BEING TOLD?
WHY IF HE WAS SAYING THAT THEN
DOES HIS ATTITUDE NOW SEEM TO BE
WELL, THE PEOPLE, YOU KNOW, WHO
NEED TO GET OUT, THEY SHOULD
HAVE BEEN GETTING OUT MUCH
EARLIER.
THEY CHOSE TO STAY THERE.
MAYBE THEY CHOSE TO STAY THERE
BECAUSE OF THE THINGS THEY WERE
HEARING FROM THE
COMMANDER-IN-CHIEF OF THE FREE
WORLD.
AND THAT'S SOMETHING THAT I
THINK IS ONLY ON HIM.
HE CANNOT PUT THAT ON DONALD
TRUMP.
HE CANNOT PUT THAT ON PREVIOUS
ADMINISTRATIONS.
IT IS ON HIM THAT HE CHOSE TO
SAY THAT.
AND IT'S ON HIM THAT IT TURNED
OUT NOT TO BE TRUE.